my name is Eric Fellini I work on  emergent gravity and I'm trying to  explain the phenomena associated to dark  matter emergent gravity is a way of  describing gravity which explains where  gravity comes from by thinking about  space-time has been built out of  microscopic quantum information this  quantum information is entangled and  from thinking about the entanglement  entropy we can derive Newton's law and  the Einstein equations but now in the  case of our universe we also have dark  energy and what I show is that from dark  energy you can actually explain using  emergent gravity what happens in  galaxies like galaxy rotation curves  that start fattening which I normally  explained through dark matter now  dark matter is then thought of as a  particle but in my theory there is no  particle a dark matter dark matter is  just a phenomenon that emerges from the  way that gravity works in our universe